[Musique]
le tout paris de la couture du cinéma et
du théâtre vient de découvrir un nouveau
couturier jean berthe et jean bart
exactement modiste de talent il coiffe
brigitte bardot et sophia loren entre
autres vedettes jean bart est présente à
la galerie neil à paris une fantastique
collection de couture réalisée
entièrement en papier
un reportage de nicole bri
[Musique]
de mémoire de couturier est d'habituer
les collections couture on n'avait
jamais vu cela
une collection entièrement réalisé en
papier et quels papiers qui
reconnaîtrait ici les rouleaux de papier
cuisine qui reconnaîtrait la les couches
de bébé et qui reconnaîtrait ici ce
papier qu'on dit utilitaire
c'est une surface suffisamment gamme de
tissus pour deux ans pas de papiers pour
pouvoir couper du sein comme un succès
non mais c'est à dire les papiers sont
superposées repris si tu veux en couture
mais là techniquement avec le vertige du
papier si tu veux je n'avais pas
l'obsession de penser d'abord sont des
mannequins statique mais je pouvais
aller un peu au delà dans les volumes
alors j'ai pris le papier j'ai
tourbillonner j'ai piqué g agrafé g
français j'ai cousu super fort et j'ai
fait faire une petite matrice là pour
faire les trous et j'ai travaillé toute
façon tous les fonds d'europe son
travail en paquets qg ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que tes robes ont
l'air d'être de vrais robe en discute
quand j'ai vu la gamme des papiers que
j'avais des papiers toilettes rose blanc
et surtout et fasse autre chose j'avais
pas les pv de collège pouvoir faire un
carnaval are you
j'ai pensé tout de suite il n'y a qu'une
chose c'est atteindre une certaine
dimension pour faire de la poésie pour
anoblir le papier le montrer sous le
même duo
des choses sublimes
c'est qu'en soirée enfin marionnettes ce
soir c'est tout
[Musique]